What's up everybody? Got some Hebrew
Israelites over here. We over here in uh
Hollywood, California. And so we're
about to see what this uh what this camp
talking about. Let's go check it out.
[Music]
What's up, brother?
>> How you doing? Do you guys have Do you
guys have open discussion?
>> Yeah, we do.
>> Yeah. Okay. Do you you guys believe I'm
sorry?
>> Ready to get out of here, bro? What's
up?
>> All right. I just want to have a
biblical discussion with you guys. I see
that you guys uh I see you guys don't
even um you you guys don't believe that
uh non-Israelites can be saved.
>> You guys don't believe that
non-Israelites can be saved.
>> Non-Israelites can be saved. Yeah. Who
said that?
>> Okay. I was just I'm asking
>> who are you?
>> I'm I'm I'm a Christian brother, man.
>> Christian brother. What's your name?
>> Yeah. Avery.
>> Huh?
>> Avery.
>> Avery. Yeah.
>> Avery. Yeah. Yeah. Nice to meet you.
What? What about you? What's your name?
>> What?
>> What's your name?
>> Taam.
>> Yeah.
>> What does it mean?
>> Huh?
>> What What does it mean?
>> Twin.
>> Twin. Okay. Tawam. All right. Nice.
>> But this is uh that's something that uh
has been taught.
>> So, how do you believe they're going to
be saved? Well, I I believe they're
going to be they get the same mic.
>> Oh, I got you.
>> Appreciate it. I didn't know y'all had a
mic over here. Yeah. Yeah, we got a mic.
Oh,
>> cool. But yeah, I believe that they get
the same salvation that uh that that
Israelites get, you know, salvation,
justification from their sins. Um you
know, uh that they're able to be
engrafted into the family of God, you
know, into the nation. So,
>> so let me ask you a question. Sure.
>> Okay. What is there a certain religion
that you believe in? I I I'm a
Christian. I believe in the Bible. I
believe in Jesus. I believe in the
Father, Son, and the Holy Spirit. I
believe that uh Jesus came to deal with
Israel. That's you. I'm talking about
I'm talking about other people that
>> are in the Baptist religion.
>> Are you asking about my my denomination?
>> Yes.
>> Oh, yeah. I don't I don't have I don't I
don't subscribe to a particular
denomination.
>> So, what about the people that do?
>> Cuz they call themselves Christians.
>> They're Christians.
>> They say they Baptist. Yeah.
>> Oh, that's perfectly fine with me. So
they do they keep the laws of the most
high?
>> Oh yeah. I mean the commandments of the
most high.
>> That's what I'm saying. And when they
talk about the commandments of the most
high, one of the commandments, the
commandment of love, the law of faith,
that's what they talk about keeping. And
especially when it comes to this idea of
cuz this this what I see this why I
asked the question. What I usually see,
and I don't know what what camp this is,
but usually camps teach that Gentiles do
not get the same salvation
uh if salvation at all as Israel. What's
salvation to you?
>> Justification for your sins that
justification for your sins. So Jesus
coming, dying, giving his life or I say
salvation is power, rulership, and
authority.
>> Okay. Now, let me get this in 1
Corinthians 15 and 24. So you know that
You know, I subscribe to a Mashiach
Yahawashi, the known savior, right?
>> Okay.
>> Okay. This one is about him. Read.
>> 1 Corinthians 15:24.
Then cometh the end.
>> So, you know the end going to come. The
end's going to come. Read.
>> When he shall have delivered up the
kingdom to the most high,
>> he going to deliver up the kingdom to
the most high. Read.
>> Even the father. when he shall put down
all rule and all authority and power.
>> That's salvation. All power, rulership,
and authority. He's coming to put down
all power, rulership, and authority.
Read
>> for he must reign till he have put all
enemies under his feet.
>> Who the enemies? He going to put all the
enemies of the most high and under
feet.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> So, we got enemies, right?
They they're named as nations in Psalms
83rd chapter.
>> Yeah,
>> you know about that.
>> Of course. Of course. There's some
nations that are against God and his
people. But then there are other nations
that are not against God and his people.
>> I'm going ask you a question. What
nation
are keeping the laws, statute,
commandments of the most high.
>> Yeah. Those are the ones who are within
the Abrahamic faith, which are the ones
who have faith. I'm talking about
>> I know. I'm trying to answer you.
>> Oh,
>> yeah. So, the ones who keep the faith in
the Messiah, right? and they are under
the law of faith. They are the ones who
are holding up the law of God and the
and the law of the Messiah. This is why
I said when you talked about rulership,
I I I'm glad you bring that up because
if we go to Revelation 5, for example,
talking about kingdom, if I I'm going to
just read this really quick in
Revelations 5, it tells us who gets that
rulership and who gets that kingdom,
right? And so in Revelation 5, let's go
down to around verses
uh here we go.
Revelation 5.
Here it is. Verse 9. It says, "And they
sang a new song, saying, worthy are you
to take the scroll and to open its seals
because you were slain and purchased for
God with your blood." So how are we
purchased? How are we saved? By the
blood of the of Christ, by the blood of
the lamb. And he says, "With your blood,
people from every tribe, every tongue,
nation, and people. And you made them
who the kingdom. You made them every
tribe, every nation, every people. You
made them to be a kingdom and priest to
our God. And they will reign on the
earth forever." So it's not just
Israelites, but the kingdom that have
that rulership is made up of all types
of nations within this kingdom.
>> So you would think that Revelation 79 it
says a great multitude would represent
all nations, right?
>> Of course,
>> you would think that, right?
>> That's what it says.
>> Yeah. But that's that's not necessarily
true.
>> Because when you deal with that right
there, when you're dealing with that,
even when it says uh what was that?
Revelation to what?
>> Revelation 5. Yeah. 59 to
>> What Bible are you reading from? Uh this
is LS LSB. You can use KJV. It's okay if
you want that
but 9 to 9 and 10 verse chapter uh
Revelation 5 9 and 10
says that the kingdom is made up of all
types of nations
every nation.
So that would include that include us.
The us is not everybody us to the most
high. That's not us. It's not to
everyone. It says, "Redeem us."
>> That is everybody.
>> It is.
>> Yeah. Cuz these same people were the
ones who Look, it says,
>> "Okay,
>> because you were slain and purchased for
God with your blood people from every
tribe."
>> Acts 5 20 27 30 and 31.
>> Wait, before you jump there, brother, do
you see how it says that you purchased
with your blood people from every tribe,
nation, people? So everyone,
>> there's a reason why I said that because
we were scattered among all nation. I
got to show you. Read.
>> Acts 5 and30. The most high power of our
fathers.
>> Of our fathers. Who is that? Who the
power? Who's our fathers? Who the power
of who? Who the most power of?
>> The four fathers. The Israelites. Is
that
>> of our fathers? Who the power of? Who
the most high the power of? He said the
power of our fathers.
>> Yeah, I just said that.
>> Who is that?
>> The power of who? He said
>> those are the four those are the
forefathers of the Israelites.
>> No, no, no. Get the power of our
fathers. Wait, stay right there. Is it
>> Exodus 3:15?
>> Wait, wait, wait. Hold on. Just real
quick, babe. You would you with all of
you? I want to go to Acts 3:13. Can we
Can we stay Can we stay focused on one
verse at a time?
>> No, we don't. No, we are. This how we
get understand to the precepts.
>> Understand to the precept. They said the
most high power of our fathers. So,
we're going to look at what the most
high power of our fathers is. You going
to you're going to define it.
>> Those are the Israelites, right?
>> No, you going to hear it. Read
>> Acts 3:13. The power of Abraham and of
Isaac and of Jacob. I said the power of
our father.
>> No, you didn't. You said the power of
Israelites.
>> No, I said I said I said the
forefathers.
>> Yeah, but the forefathers.
>> Who are they?
>> That's Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob.
>> No, no, no. It could be Daniel. Is that
our forefathers?
>> That that includes that includes them as
well. I'm saying not the power of them,
too.
>> Without you got to understand, it's
specific without a shadow of a doubt. He
said the power of our fathers. So, it's
define who the power of our fathers is
right here. the power of Abraham, Isaac,
and Jacob. Go to Exodus 3:15.
>> Can can I comment on this really quick
because I I think this is important what
you just brought up, how God is the
power of the the the fathers, right? The
forefathers, Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob
specifically because when it comes to
the covenant and the promise God made
with Abraham, this is what he says in
Genesis 12:3. He says that it's in you
that all the families of the earth will
be blessed. So talking about God and his
connection with Abraham, the covenant he
makes, he promises initially that all
the families, not just Israelite
families, will be included in that
blessing. So how is it that you can
include everybody in this salvation?
>> There's no judgment for the people that
have not been judged on this earth.
>> Of course, there's not a judge. I mean,
that's what I'm saying. But you got to
look at where are they at. I'm just
trying to say you're saying what you're
saying, but show me a people. No, I'm
watching the people this day in this
time
>> that love you
>> that love me that love us period.
They don't even I've been asking for 4
months. They don't even know the most
high. The most high you know is the most
high.
So they the same. Yes,
>> they're the same. See that's what we
disagree right there.
>> Okay, that's cool. That's but that's the
second subject though. Okay. I think
y'all know who he is. I really
try to try to come up in a
Bris about what about description?
>> What about nothing to do with Bryce
Carpet? Hold on. Let
>> Let me say what you just said, bro. Let
me comment on what you just said cuz I'm
listen about what you about what you
just said about uh who loves you and
stuff like that, right? I I want to talk
to you about that because one,
>> that has nothing to do with the verses
that I'm bringing up. We got to deal
with the verses. So, the verses that I'm
that I'm bringing up you got though. I
mean, you saying what you're saying. I'm
here. I'm where you at. I gave you where
you at.
>> Okay. So, I gave you two. I gave Wait,
listen. You I gave up. You came to my
zone.
>> I know, but I came to my zone and I
dealt with what you're talking about.
Look, I gave you Revelation 5. Look, I
gave you
>> Wow. I I I gave you Revelation 5.
>> Yeah. You haven't dealt with that.
>> I am dealing with And I gave you the And
I gave you the promise.
>> Give me the Bible written.
>> I gave you the promise of God to
Abraham.
>> You going to look at how the Bible's
written. Okay. Christians said you want
to know what deal with I'm You say
you're a Christian, right?
>> Yeah.
>> You're a Christian. You know where that
word comes from?
>> Yes.
>> Where it come from? It
>> it's it's when uh they got this name in
Antioch. Be a Christ or a little Christ.
>> That was a that was that was
>> in Acts 11.
>> That was demeaning to them.
>> No, it wasn't.
>> It was man. You know, Christian come
read this.
>> You're changing the subject again,
brother.
>> No, no, we ain't changing sub. We going
to deal with
We going to deal with Revelation 5, too.
Read this. Let's get there. It says
where you what you said. I'm going to
give you some definitions since you
don't know. You debating everybody. Read
this. That's the word Christian comes
from.
>> Cretton.
>> Yeah. Where it come from? The word what?
>> Uhhuh.
>> Word or from French. Word [__] from
Swiss French. [__]
>> What are you reading?
>> From Latin word Christian.
>> Christristenius.
>> Christinius. Christians alluding to the
humanity of such persons or people.
Handicapped.
>> Handicapped
>> meaning poor fellow.
>> Poor fellow. Read as a noun. as in now.
A person considered to be extremely
stupid. A what? A person considered to
be extremely stupid. A person what?
Considered to be extremely stupid. What
did it say? What did it say? A person
considered to be extremely stupid.
>> Britain dictionary uh dictionary
definition for [__] A person
suffering from creatinism.
as stupid, obtuse, or slow to understand
or perceive or mentally defective. No,
>> look it up on yourself. That's what that
what you say you are. We don't we don't
subscribe to that, man. I mean, we've
been all over the world dealing with
what we need to deal with promos.
Peromos. I mean, you got to look at what
it is that you you're saying this means.
>> Can I get Can I get a response really
quick? All right. So you guys you guys
gave me I didn't even know what you guys
were quoting from, but this is Strong's
concordance. Strong's exhaustive
concordance. It says, "A Christian, i.e.
definition, a follower of Christ."
>> So hold on just
look at this.
>> Y'all love strong usually. So we got we
got the definition. We like definitions.
The definition of Christian is to be a
follower of Christ according to the
biblical definition. But hold on a
second. Now this is why why we see do do
we see this definition in the Bible?
Yes. For example, when we look at Acts
26:28, I know you know this where uh uh
a grippa says this. It says, "But a
gripper replied to Paul in such uh in
such short time you are persuading me to
become a Christian." He's like, "You you
almost got me to become a Christian,
right?"
>> Watch what Paul says in response to
this. And Paul said, "I will pray to God
that what that whether in a short or
long time, not only you, a grippa, who's
an Edomite, by the way, but also who uh
but also all who hear me this day, might
become such as I am except for these
chains." So even with this, look, but
notice how the Holy Spirit led us here.
The you bringing up this topic led us to
a verse where one being a Christian is
dignified because you're a follower of
Christ and two Paul hopes that an
Edomite becomes a Christian.
>> Yeah, but what about following the high
walls man?
>> There's what why you switching sub I'm
switching on subs that's what Israelites
do man
I'm talking about as far as dealing with
how the Bible's written.
>> You're not dealing with it accept that
because you got to understand man.
>> Give me Let me get right to get out of
here. No, I'm I'm going to deal with
this.
>> You got to deal with this.
>> Yeah, because the fact of what?
>> He going to become what?
>> No, no, we're not talking about what
because he's an Edomite. He's an
Edomite.
>> Edomite. Edomite, right?
>> And he
>> this going to happen to him.
>> Wait, is he is he an Edomite?
>> He's Edomite.
>> So why does Paul hope that he becomes a
Christian?
>> Because he want him to be he want him to
learn what we're learning.
>> Oh, so why would Paul you supposed to be
learning what we're teaching? That's
>> why would Paul want an Edomite to learn
what he's learning. What would that be?
>> Because he get a chance to be in the
kingdom. So Edom might be in the
kingdom.
>> Not yet.
>> Oh man, that's beautiful. I like that.
>> Yeah. Let's Let's look how though.
>> I like that.
>> Let's look. Is it about how though?
>> Give me uh Jeremiah 12:16. Get right to
the point. This is what it's all about.
>> So is being a Christian a good thing?
>> Huh?
>> Is being a Christian a good thing?
>> It's not a good thing.
>> So why does Paul say he hopes that he be
that that a grippa becomes that just
like he is?
>> Because I'm going show you why. Read
this.
>> Jeremiah 12:16. And it shall come to
pass.
>> Come to pass. We're looking for this.
Read
>> this. What you this what you already
think you in but you ain't in yet. Read.
>> All right.
>> If they will diligently learn the ways
of my people.
>> That's why Paul's saying what he's
saying. You supposed to learn the ways
of the Israelites. Read
>> to swear by my name.
>> Swear by the Most High's name. What's
his name?
>> Who?
>> Huh?
>> Who who's he talking about?
>> These other nations
>> talking
>> outside of the 12 tribes of Israel. Like
you saying like a group he's a Pet
Edomite or whoever whatever nation. Read
the swear by his name. What's his name?
I I identify himself as what?
>> Yahweh.
>> No.
>> Yes. I'm talking about fathers who I
identify his name as he said the name of
our father we just we
>> said his name is Yahweh that's his
everlasting name
>> that's that's Yiddish
>> that's what
>> Yiddish
>> what what is Yiddish
>> huh
>> what is Yiddish
>> that's the Jewish people language
>> what they created
>> you know Yiddish
>> yeah read this
>> do you know Yiddish
>> I learned I I know how to do how to
transfer it from your language to my
language
>> do you know Yiddish
>> to uh um ancient Hebrew how to translate
it from there it's only 19 it's only 22
characters in um
>> the Hebrew character. You can look at
Psalm 199.
>> I'm asking, do you know Yiddish? Do you
know it?
>> The language?
>> I don't know it completely.
>> So, how do you know that Yahweh is a
Yiddish word? How do you know Yahweh is
a Yiddish word?
>> They created it. How do you know? You
don't know. Listen at this. Read
>> Exodus 3:15. And the Most High said
moreover unto Moses, thus shall thou say
unto the children of Israel.
>> To who?
>> The children of Israel.
>> Children of Israel. Yahawah, the power
of your fathers.
>> Power of who?
>> Your fathers. The power of Abraham, the
power of Isaac, and the power of Jacob
have sent me unto you. This is my name
forever. What's his name? This is my
name forever. He's the power of Abraham,
who had a son named Isaac, who had a son
named Jacob. You say, what is his name?
This is my name forever.
>> Jacob is the forefather of the 12 tribes
of Israel. who was Judah, Bishop, Levi,
Simeon, Zephylon, Ephra, Manessa, Gad,
Ruben, Napali, Astra, and Issachar.
Read.
>> And this is my memorial unto all
generations.
>> His memorial to all generations. That's
how we identify him. If you're not of of
Jacob, then he's not your power. Go to
back to Jeremiah 12. Let me respond to
that. Go respond to that.
>> You just said that if you're not of
Jacob, then he's not his he's not his
power.
>> No, he said he said our fathers, the
father of who? Abraham, Isaac, and
Jacob.
>> That's in the context of him dealing
with Israelites. That's not in the
context of accepting the Gentiles as
well. This is what This is why I said
hold on just really quick. This is why I
said you're not dealing with the verses
that talk about how every people from
every tribe, nation, and tongue are
going to be a kingdom. They're going to
be the kingdom who are purchased. So how
you need to describe to me how is it
listen how is it that not that people
from every single nation not just the
nation of Israel that's one nation
>> every other nation as well are a kingdom
of God explain that you got to break
that down in revelation in re look in
revelation 5
>> they're not they're not the king of
>> brother I just read this to you bro look
>> at Jeremiah
>> let's get to Jeremiah we going to bring
this out no it ain't I was bringing it
out Before you even go back to After you
look at this, you going to respond on
this. Read you promise.
>> This is the book of Jeremiah 12:16. And
it shall come to pass if they will
diligently learn the ways of my people.
>> So everybody's going to be learning the
ways that we are teaching as Israelites.
Read
>> to swear by my name.
>> Swear by his name, the power of Abraham,
Isaac, and Jacob. We going to use that
name because that's that's what we said.
His name is forever the memorial to all
generations. Read. And Jacob being the
forefather of the 12 tribes of Israel.
Read. The Most High live.
>> Most high live. Read. That's way.
>> As they taught my people to swear by B A
L.
>> Think about it, ma'am. How did they
teach the Most High's people to swear by
B A L?
>> Is it okay that I can we can get back to
the verses now?
>> How did they teach the Most High's
people?
>> Notice how you're notice how you're
switching and shuffling to another.
>> You came to my phone, so I'm running it.
>> Yeah, but you're we going to deal with
we going to deal with what you're
talking about.
>> I know you're running it. I'm saying
that you're running away from running
away. You going to listen what? Listen
to what I'm saying because I've been
here.
>> It's going right. It's going to come to
a point where you're going to have to
give an answer to what I'm saying. I've
been Look, you haven't you brought you
brought up Acts 5. You brought up Acts
5. You dealt with Abra. You talked about
Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob. I dealt with
all of that. I gave you even verses to
what I'm saying. No, listen. You even
brought up uh the kingdom and what
salvation means is rulership and
authority. Right. So I I'm answering you
directly by giving you Bible verses that
tell you who's going to be in that
authority and kingdom.
>> Right. I'm tell not not authority, but
they going to be in the kingdom. I said
I said they going to be in the kingdom.
They don't have no authority.
>> No. No. Look, it says they don't have no
authority. It says you made them to be a
kingdom. Does that mean they have the
authority?
>> That's that's the Israelites.
>> Okay, I got you. Does that mean that
they're the authority? If they are a
kingdom,
>> we we the kingdom of the most high.
>> So if you are a kingdom, are you the
authority?
>> Yeah.
>> Excellent.
>> Along with the most high first and
foremost.
>> All right. I like that.
>> And you're going to have other people
that's going to be right there in the
middle with us.
>> All right, I'm building with you. So
look, he says, "You have made them a
kingdom." Who did he make a kingdom?
Watch.
>> Not just Israel. He says, "Every tribe
and nation and tongue and language and
people. And you made that. Let me
finish. Let me finish. I know.
>> And you made them to be a kingdom, the
same people,
>> okay?
>> And priests to our God." So it's not
just Israel that's of God. God is there
is the power of the Gentiles.
>> Let's deal with that. Let's deal with
that. All right. Give me Deuteronomy
28:20 64.
>> Oh man.
>> This what happened. This is what
happened. That's what y'all y'all like I
say.
>> You too close. You too close. You too
close to chapter 29.
>> We going to deal with We going to deal
with why it says that.
>> 29 going to cut you tongue. No, it
ain't. Read.
>> All right.
>> Deuteronomy 28:64.
And the Most High shall scatter thee
among all people.
>> It's us. We going to scatter us among
all people. Read
>> from the one end of the earth even unto
the other
>> even to the other. Read
>> and there
>> we be scattered among all these nations.
Read
>> thou shalt serve other gods.
>> That's why we can sell be serving all
kind of different religions and so forth
right now to this day. Read
>> which neither thou nor thy fathers have
known.
>> All these religions that you believe in
now, you think they they were known in
the time that Moses talking to us in the
in the wilderness. No, they're not.
They're new. There's something new that
came up. What?
>> Even wood and stone. and Buddhist stone,
Christianity, Buddha, Islam, all these
different things, right? So then he told
us Paul's religion
>> in uh
Genesis 35 and 10.
>> So you're saying Paul's religion is
something new?
>> Paul's cuz you said Christianity. So
Paul's religion is something new.
>> Yeah, it's true. It's not new. He was
Israelite. He was an Israelite.
>> So why did he claim to be a Christian?
He
>> were Israelite.
>> Why did he claim
>> when he was sent to the Israelites that
was scattered among all these people? He
said he claim to be a Christian.
>> Genesis 35 and 10. Now dealing with vers
said unto him, "Thy name is Jacob. Thy
name shall not be called anymore Jacob."
>> This is when Jacob name was changed.
Read.
>> But Israel shall be thy name.
>> What?
>> Israel shall be thy name. What's going
come out of Israel?
>> And he called his name Israel. And the
Most High said unto him,
>> you tell what the Most High tell Jacob.
>> I am the most high almighty. Be fruitful
and multiply
>> of a lot of children cuz he had four
wives. Read
>> a nation.
>> A nation read.
>> And a company of nations.
>> There go your company of nations right
there. A nation and a company of
nations. Read
>> shall be of thee.
>> shall be of thee. Re
>> and kings shall come out of thy loins.
>> Kings going to come out of his loins and
priests going to come out of his loins.
>> All right. So let me let me respond to
this. I like this all. So So when it
comes to these promises and the covenant
of Israel, are Gentiles included in the
covenant?
>> No.
>> Okay. So here's here's You went to
Deuteronomy, right? Yeah. The covenant.
All right. So watch this. You went to
Deuteronomy 28. I'm about to give you
Deuteronomy 29, the very next chapter.
Watch what it says here. Deuteronomy 29.
It says verse 10. It says, "You stand
today, all of you, before Yahweh our
God, your God, your heads, your elders,
your tribes, your officers, all the men
of Israel." So all the men of Israel are
together. That's all the 12 tribes,
right? Okay. Now, so that's all the 12
tribes are accounted for. Now watch
this. It says, "Your little ones and
your wives." So now the children and the
wives of the is of the Israelites. So
all of Israel is accounted for the men,
their children, and their wives. Now
watch this. Are you
>> alone? Hold on.
>> Why you hold up? Are you Are you with
vocab?
>> Are you with vocab?
>> Man, it sounds something familiar that
something sounded familiar to me. Is
>> he with vocab? this Bible.
>> Help me with this. Huh?
>> I'm going to tell you why this sound
familiar to you. Cuz you might be the
sheep of Jesus. He might be calling you
out of this mess, man. Listen,
>> let me let me finish.
>> Go ahead. Verse 11.
>> All right. Verse 11. Watch this. So your
little ones, your wives. So all of
Israel is counted for you. You
listening, brother? So watch this. It
says, "And the sojourer, that's not an
Israelite. and the stranger, the
sojourer who is within your camp, from
the one who chops your wood to the one
who draws your water, that you may enter
the covenant with Yahweh your God in and
into his oath which Yahweh your God is
is cutting with you today. So um in
order sorry in order that he may
establish you today as his people
including the strangers who are not
Israelites uh as his people
>> the two kinds of strangers
>> and that well we'll see and that he may
be your God just as he spoke to you and
as he swore to your fathers to Abraham,
Isaac, and Jacob. So right here we see
that strangers really quick. We we see
we see the Israelites are all accounted
for. We see the strangers who are
non-Israelites in Moses's camp. They're
also included in the covenant. So this
doctrine that the Isra the Gentiles are
not included in the covenant is false
doctrine. Bro, this is why you got to go
back to the beginning.
>> 105 8-2.
>> This is the book of Psalms 105 and8.
>> Can we deal with the verse?
>> He has remembered his covenant.
>> Talking about the covenant,
>> brother. You have every verse I brought
up.
>> The word which he commanded to a
thousand generations. The covenant he
commanded to a thousand generations. Who
he made the covenant with?
>> Which covenant he made with Abraham.
>> Made the covenant with Abraham.
>> And his oath unto Isaac.
>> Oath unto Isaac. Right.
>> And confirm the same unto Jacob.
>> Confirmed the same unto Jacob for what?
>> For a law and to Israel for an
everlasting covenant.
>> To Israel for an everlasting covenant.
>> All right. That's beautiful.
>> Israel for an everlasting covenant. Not
everybody. Oh, if that's not everybody,
then why? I'm glad that you brought up
the origin of the covenant that God made
generations ago. This is what it says.
The covenant, and I will bless those who
bless you, and the one who curses you, I
will curse. And in you, all
all the families of the earth will be
blessed. You're going back to the
original covenant where God originally
promises to include all the families of
the earth to be part of the covenant,
including, which is an example of this.
Hold on. Just really quick, brother. An
example of this is Deuteronomy 29, where
the stranger is included in the
covenant.
>> All right. Now,
>> can you deal with that, please?
>> I'm going to deal with it. I want I want
you to ask me one question.
>> Oh my god.
>> Brother,
>> who are you so concerned about? Cuz you
ain't concerned about all people.
>> I'm concerned about you. You ain't
concerned about me.
>> I'm concerned about you. Because you're
out here about other people. You're
concerned about other people.
>> I'm concerned about you, man. You
concerned about other nations.
>> Right now, you're not in the family of
Abraham yet. You got a false gospel.
You're you you you you're trying to what
y'all trying to do is see y'all see that
we're so powerful in the earth right
now.
>> Why you ain't right down there teaching?
I want you to come next week and go
right down there and teach what you
teach.
>> I'll tell you why I'm not down there
teaching because the people who need
teaching is right here.
>> No, you teach us teaching. Go back to
Jeremiah. Go back to listen to scripture
before. No, you going to listen to this.
>> Every time I try to bring this up always
stop listening.
Come on. What's your name?
>> You angry. You angry. Come on. Listen to
the script. Every time I try to bring it
out, y'all always stop me. Always stop
126. Listen. Listen. Promise. Listen.
Every time. They always stop, right?
They always stop. Yah.
Listen. No. No.
My mic off, man.
>> Jeremiah. Listen. Listen.
>> They going to turn my mic off because I
want you to hear these two scriptures.
That's all. Then we going to deal with
Listen. Listen. They going to turn my
mic off. They going to mute me up.
>> And they will diligently go the ways of
my people.
>> Say that again.
>> I'm just trying to learn.
Yeah. They're preaching a false gospel.
They're trying to say that not only
Israelites, which are like blacks,
native Americans, they're the only ones
that can receive salvation from God. So
I'm trying to show them that no,
according to God's covenant, he includes
all the family. God is not just the God
of the Jews, but of every
preaching gospel. What is B, man? Yeah,
for sure, man. Huh? Listen, bro.
He just came for his own doubt, man. I
just I said two scriptures. That's all I
want you to bring out.
>> I never can bring these two scriptures
out.
>> Every time I bring these scriptures out,
it's always a distraction. I'm saying,
man, that ain't going. There's something
wrong with that.
>> Turn my mic off, man.
>> No, because you going you going to
interrupt these two scriptures,
brother. We've been having a good back
and forth.
>> We don't have a back and forth. I just
want to do these two scriptures.
>> So you going to mute me? You going to
mute me out? Yeah, because I want you to
hear these two scriptures. Two
scriptures and then you look you gave me
your word. You were dealing with
Revelation 5.
I've been dealing with it, bro. They
will diligently learn the ways of my
people.
>> God digitally learned the ways of we the
Israelites teaching
>> to swear by my name.
>> Swear by the Most High's name. Not no
Yahweh but the power of Abraham, Isaac,
and Jacob. Jacob being the forefather of
the 12 tribes of Israel. Right.
>> Most high living.
>> Most high living cuz you live forever.
We just That's all we going to talk
about him all day long. Right.
>> As they taught my people to swear by B A
L. You know they taught our people to
swear by B A L.
By putting what in the Bible? By putting
L O R D. That's what B A L means. L O R
D. And they put it in the Bible. And
that's what people be calling on. You
probably calling on them yourself, man.
That's why you smiling, right? They they
made our people swear by P A L which is
L O R D.
>> Give me my turn to speak.
>> Then shall they be built in the midst of
my people.
>> You hear what he said?
>> What did he say? This a condition. This
is a condition. This a condition. What
did he say?
>> It says then shall they be built in the
midst of my people.
>> Then they're going to be built in the
midst of the Most High's people. If they
learn the ways that we are teaching from
this Bible, man, straight up. All right.
Then would they be built in the midst of
the Most High's people who are the
Israelites? Read. But
>> you said condition. You said you said
two verses.
>> So you telling me what I can do now,
right?
>> No, you told me. Oh, you got I'm going
to hold your verse now, man.
>> You just read No, y'all ain't got no
patience, man.
>> Brother, I I've been a no patience. You
muted my mic. Mut my mic.
>> Yeah. The spirit and one of those is
truth, right? You got to tell the truth.
Just a second verse. Just a second
verse. This is the second verse. Look, I
mean it's like I mean
>> Wow, man. What's up, man? I mean, just
the second verse.
>> Imagine sitting here patiently listening
to my older brother here. I'm listening
patiently. You turn my mic off and I
>> because I I can never get these
scriptures.
>> I heard you read multiple verses.
>> No, you heard me read one verse.
>> Okay. So, you going to read? You about
to read the second one and then we can
back get back to engaging.
>> I'm going to break it down first because
that's how you got to understand the
Bible.
>> Okay.
>> Right. Right. What you talking about? We
just going to read it. All you do is
read scriptures. Don't talk. You've been
talking reading scriptures and talking
running your mouth. This is how you been
reading scriptures. This is how you know
they don't want a discussion. When they
fear discussion, they cut your mic off
and then they start talking over you on
the microphone. Luckily, I got my own
mic. So, yay.
They don't like to go Bible for Bible.
They can't go verse for verse.
>> I I can't go verse for verse.
>> No, you can't. I'm doing it right now.
>> You ain't deal with a single can never
get this scripture out. All I want to do
is two scriptures and you keep talking.
You have it. You keep in your mouth.
Liquid
time. Can you be quiet?
>> All right. How about this? I'll be quiet
right now. After you read your verse, do
you give me your word that we're going
to deal with these passages?
>> We can deal with whatever. I'm saying
what I'm saying. I got to get out of
here. I got I got a holy complication to
deal with.
>> You know, you should have came up early.
I'd have been really really running to
deal with you all day long. We got a I
got a I got a holy complication I got to
deal with.
>> I'm listening. What time is it?
>> Time to time to run.
>> 5:40. No. We got host
>> ain't trying to run. You can come up
next Saturday. We be here next next next
Saturday.
>> Yeah, we be here all day long.
>> Y'all here every weekend.
>> Here all day long. Every weekend, you
know. Y'all know
where we at.
>> You know, maybe all the rest of y'all
know where we at. Here come here, right?
But read this.
>> Now I know where y'all at.
>> It says uh Jeremiah 12 and 17.
>> 16. And it shall come to pass if they
will diligently learn the ways of my
people. All they got to do is learn the
ways of the Most High's people. What
we're teaching, read
>> to swear by my name.
>> Swear by his name. Acknowledge that the
Most High is a power. Abraham, Isaac,
and Jacob. Jacob being the forefather of
the 12 tribes of Israel. Read.
>> The Most High live.
>> Most high live. Breathe.
>> As they taught my people to swear by B A
L.
>> They taught the Most High's people to
swear by B A. That means L O R D. And
we're spelling it because we're not
supposed to let the name of other gods
come out of our mouths. Read. And they
put it all in the Bible. You see it all
in the Bible. L O R D. Read.
>> Then shall they be built in the midst of
my people.
>> Then those Gentiles you talking about
going to be built in the midst of the
Most High's people. Read. But what?
>> Verse 17. But if they will not obey,
>> they will not obey what? If they will
not obey these other nations don't want
to obey what?
>> If they will, And it shall come to pass.
If they will diligently learn the ways
of my people,
>> they don't want to learn the ways that
we're teaching from this Bible.
the only way the truth of this Bible
read.
>> But if they will not obey,
>> they don't want to obey, breed.
>> I will utterly pluck up and destroy that
nation, saith the Most High, utterly
pluck up and destroy that nation, sayeth
the Most High. Okay, that's what they
got to do. Now, if you want to go
further from what they got to do and
where they going to be at in the midst
of the Most High's people, that's
another subject. You know what I mean?
That's that answers what it said here.
>> All right. No,
>> because they going to, like I said, they
going to be in the kingdom.
>> I got you.
>> But they got certain position that what
what position are you in in this
kingdom?
>> I got you.
>> What What position are we in as a people
in this kingdom?
>> Me and the other Gentiles are priests.
We're priests according to Revelation 5.
>> Y'all running everything.
>> Okay. You got power ruling authority
here.
>> I want to deal with this. Okay. When we
talking about the covenant is what we
just talked about in Deuteronomy.
>> The agreement that the most high made
with Abraham, Jacob.
>> Yep. That all the families of the earth
will be blessed. Now my question to you
say I'm blessed cuz we were in captivity
under every nation and when we did they
all every time we were in the captivity
under a nation they superpower the
earth.
>> Were there non-Israelites that was in
the camp of Moses in Deuteronomy?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. And were these non-Israelites
sworn into the covenant?
>> No, they weren't sworn into covenant.
>> So when Deuteronomy 29 says who I want
to know who are these who are these
strangers in the camp strangers donated.
>> That's right. She what I'm saying cuz
she understands. All right. So, so who
are who are the strangers in Deuteronomy
29?
>> You got two different types of
strangers, right?
>> Just really quick. I I hear you. It says
all the men of Israel. Who are they? Who
are all the men of Israel?
>> The men of Israel.
>> Okay. And who are the wives?
>> They're wives.
>> Are they Israelites?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Good. Who are their children? Are
they Israelites?
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So all the men of Israel,
every single man that is an Israelite,
every wife, every woman that's an
Israelite, every son and daughter that's
an Israelite are all accounted for.
Correct?
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. Who is the stranger?
>> The strangers could be those that are
not that you don't know. You a stranger
to me, but you're an Israelite, but you
are still a stranger.
>> Who are the strangers? Are they
>> those that come in that that could be
strangers?
>> So So they're not Israelites.
>> They could be they could they don't have
to be they don't have to be other
nations. They could be strangers of of
Israelites. They could be Israelites.
>> Okay. Just so just to be clear in
Deuteronomy 29
>> after the Exodus there are stranger
Israelites among the Israelites.
>> Yeah it could be
>> how
>> how because just like right now we we in
captivity slavery in bondage right and
some like you you feel you're free you
you feel like you you were you were they
different you're a different structure
than us.
>> Were they in bondage in Deuteronomy 29
were they in bondage were they in
bondage in Deuteronomy 29? Was a great
multitude.
>> I got you. Were they Israelites? This
>> What?
>> This multitude. Were they Israelites?
>> Israelites and other with us.
>> You have the people with us going to be
joined with us in the doc. We read just
now right there with
>> I'm talking about the context of
Deuteronomy. Okay. In Deuteronomy, were
there Israelites strangers of other
Israelites?
>> What do you mean strangers of other
>> Okay. Uh that's what I'm saying. You
cannot be a str if you're an Israelite,
you're not a stranger to an Israelite.
The strangers are non-Israelites. Do you
agree? No. A stranger is somebody you
don't know.
>> Oh my.
>> Okay.
>> Isn't it?
>> No.
>> Aren't you a stranger to me?
>> So a stranger don't mean somebody that
you don't know
>> in the Bible. Is is it somebody that you
don't know?
>> You got two type of strangers.
>> You got stranger that you don't know.
That's Israel. You a stranger to me as
an Israelite. So now you got the other n
strangers too. One second. That's other
nations.
>> Do they do they if they are if they are
do they not part of the covenant? We
just covenant.
>> Okay. Are they So these strangers
>> So you put you put these strangers in
the covenant.
>> These strangers are they with the
Israelites?
>> They're they're wrong. They came out of
of the captivity with us, right?
>> Okay. So, they're with them, right?
Yeah. So, they know them.
>> Yeah.
>> So, how are they still strangers?
>> They're stranger because they're the
other nations.
>> There you go. Beautiful. I love that.
>> If they don't they don't get they don't
get the covenant.
>> Okay. They don't get the covenant.
>> If they don't get the covenant, I just
read who get the covenant. Abraham,
Isaac, Jacob, and Israel.
>> Let's see. So, I'm I I love your I love
your admission. So, let me get my verse,
right? Okay. I'm going to do this again
for you, bro. I need you to deal You
promised me you would deal with this.
Mhm.
>> So this is now the strangers who are
other nations, non-Israelites. You
taking notes?
>> Okay, you silent. So not do, man. Don't
worry about just making sure. I'm just
making sure. So watch this. Here it is
again.
>> Y'all Y'all look for hype, huh? Y'all
trying
a good time, man.
>> No, no. You hype. We having a good time.
We having a good time, man.
>> Come on. Cuz I only got a few bits out.
I got I respect your time. So look, it
says you stand today.
>> Where you at?
>> Uh Deuteronomy 29:10.
Mhm.
>> You with me so far? Okay. It's the same
scripture. All right. I got you that
you've been reading over and over again.
>> Yes. I need you to deal with it. You
stand today, all of you, not some of
you. All of you before Yahweh your God,
your heads, your tribes, your elders,
your officers.
>> Even brother, I need you to listen.
You're not listening to me.
>> I'm listening. I'm listening.
>> No, but you trying to get another verse,
right? I need your attention here.
>> I'm listening.
>> You promise? Yeah. I believe me, I grew
up multitasking.
>> All right. I need you with me, man. I'll
hear you.
>> All right. And it says, "And all the men
of Israel."
>> Then it says, "Your little ones and your
wives." So all of the Israelites are
accounted for. Every man, woman, and
child that's an Israelite. Then it says,
"And the stranger who you just said are
of the other nations, not the
Israelites."
>> And I said,
>> uh-huh.
>> Also a str. You a stranger to me.
>> No. No. No, you did not. You had you.
I'm saying there's two types of
strangers I've seen.
>> No, no, no. What we
>> They are.
>> So, how are they still strangers?
>> They're stranger because they're all the
nations. They're all the nations.
They're all the nations. They're all the
nations.
>> What we solidified is in Deuteronomy 29.
This is what I asked you specifically. I
asked you who are these and you said
these are of the other nations. Okay.
>> I told you that Israelites, strangers,
or they could be another nation.
>> We already we already broke that first
thing down. All right. Now, so these
strangers are the non-Israelites. Watch
what happens with them. Who is within
your camps? From the one who chops your
wood to the one who draws your water
that you everybody here that you may
enter into the covenant with Yahweh your
God and into his oath which Yahweh your
God is cutting with you today. So guess
who's included in the covenant? The
strangers who are not Hold on, let them
listen. The strangers who are
non-Israelites are part of the covenant.
They're sworn into the covenant.
>> Well, where does it go any further to
say that?
>> It just said it right here. What are you
talking about?
>> One scripture.
>> I just read it to you.
>> What does it say? That the other nations
are in the covenant of the most high.
>> Let me read. You want to read Jeremiah
31:31.
>> Strangers among you that you may be
sworn into the covenant of your life.
>> Okay. Now, I read it once in Psalms 105
8-10. Now, let's read it in Hebrews 8.
>> Can you deal with this?
>> Right. Hey, I got to deal with the New
Testament first.
>> No, bro. No,
>> no, no, no. We got to deal with it cuz
if that's a fact, if that's a fact, you
promise me I am dealing with
I'm going to deal with this.
>> No, brother. Don't go nowhere.
>> I have to because you have to make it
make sense.
>> Who are these? Who are these strangers?
>> You got to be Israel. Listen. Hebrews 8
and 8. I mean, look, you got two types
of strangers now. I told you that. But
I'm not I'm standing on that. I'm going
>> for finding fought with them. He's
fighting fought with us with the
Israelites. Beh. the days to come,
sayeth the most high, when I will make a
new covenant. New covenant, new
contract, a new agreement,
>> with the house of Israel. I'm going to
end it with you.
>> The house of Israel.
>> House of Israel. And who?
>> And with the house of Judah.
>> The house of Judah. The northern tribes
and the southern tribes.
>> Not according to the covenant that I
made with their fathers in the day when
I took them by the hand to lead them out
of the land of Egypt.
>> That cancels out. That cancels out what
you was talking about. Oh, does it? What
did it say? Not what
>> it says, not according to the covenant
that I made with their fathers.
>> Their fathers in the wilderness. Right.
That's where you're reading from me. In
the wilderness in Deuteronomy, read
>> in the day when I took them by the hand
to lead them out of the land of Egypt.
>> Hey, they took us by the hand to lead us
out of the the land of Israel. I mean
Egypt, cuz we were in captivity on the
Egypt since re because they continue not
in my covenant.
>> Who was the covenant given to? the
Israelites, man. We continue not in this
covenant, but we broke his laws. Re and
I regarded them not.
>> Regarded us not. Put us in captivity
over and over and over again. When you
reading the Bible under these strangers,
you can look out for it. Re say the most
high.
>> Who said it?
>> Sayaith the most high.
>> Go ahead.
>> For this is the covenant that I will
make with the house of Israel,
>> with everybody.
>> With the house of Israel.
>> No, it got to be with the Gentiles and
the strangers and the foreigners and all
these people that they want to bring in.
Who say with who? with the house of
Israel.
>> What are you going to do
>> after those days?
>> After those days, what are you going to
do?
>> Sayaith the most high.
>> Who said this?
>> Got to do with the most high on this.
What did he say?
>> Sayaith the most high, I will put my
laws into their mind.
>> His laws into our minds. Read.
>> And write them in their hearts.
>> Write them in our spirit and mind. Read.
>> And I will be to them a power.
>> Be to us, the Israelites, a power. Read.
>> And they shall be to me a people. be the
most high of people. Man,
>> can I respond to that?
>> He didn't include no one else but the
Israelites.
>> Oh, really? Okay. Now, I'm about to
break this down to you real quick. Watch
this. So, this is Isaiah 42. I'm going
to give you Isaiah 42 and then I'm going
to give you another verse in Isaiah
that's going that just cut you. So, this
is Isaiah 42 talking about the covenant
and who's it given to? I agree that the
covenant is given to Israel, which we
saw that the strangers are part of the
house of Israel, the non-Israelites.
Now, watch this. Hold on a second. Watch
this. Watch this. Watch this. Behold my
servant. Behold my servant. Behold my
No, it was servants. Even the Israelites
were servants, were they not? Of each
other? No. No. Were the Israelites
servants of each other?
>> Thank you. Yeah. So stay in your lane,
brother. So the Israelites were servants
of each other just like Gentiles are
servants of Israelites. And Israelites
also served the Gentiles in Leviticus
25. Let's talk about that. We serve all
even a stranger bond. All right. Watch
this. Look now, brother. Watch this.
Watch this. So it says you with him.
>> Well, let's see. It says, "Behold my
servant." In Isaiah 42 Isaiah 42 1 1 1-6
it says, "Behold my servant whom I
uphold, my chosen one in whom my soul
delights. I have put my spirit upon him.
He will bring forth justice to the
nations. He will not cry out or raise
his voice nor make his voice heard in
the street. A crushed reed he will not
break, and a faintly burning wick he
will not extinguish." I'm going to jump
down to verse 6. Watch this. And it says
here, "I am Yahweh. I have called you in
righteousness. I will also
>> I will also take hold of you and give
you as a covenant to the people a light
for the Gentiles. So who's the covenant
given to here? To Gentiles. Is that
correct?
>> Yeah. But the other the northern tri the
northern tribes were called Gentiles.
>> Who are because they had left the
covenant. They left they had left the
covenant.
>> Is the covenant given to Gentiles here?
>> Yeah. But the Gentiles are the northern
tri. Now watch this. I got I got one
more. No, Gentiles are not the other
nations here. It's talking about the
northern tribes.
>> We'll see. So, watch this. I'm going to
show you. Wait. I got one more verse. Go
ahead. I got one more verse. So, watch
this. When I go to Isaiah,
>> Isaiah what?
>> I'm about to show you real quick. Isaiah
19.
>> It said righteousness, didn't it? In
that verse you just read, didn't it say
righteousness? They supposed to become
the righteousness. What's righteousness?
>> The righteousness that the Messiah
bestows on them through his work. Not
righteousness is is keeping the laws of
the most high.
>> But Jesus says that the law the the law
cannot give you righteousness. It's him.
He's the one who gives you
righteousness.
>> No, he's just an example to show us how
we can follow the laws. He was an
example that came in and kept the
commandments of the most high. That's
what he's saying.
>> I got you. Who did you say was was the
Most High's people? Who' you say they
were?
>> Who' you say the Most High's people
>> The children of Israel tribes.
>> I got you. So watch this. This is Isaiah
19.
>> Mhm.
>> Verse 24 and 25. Watch this. It says,
"In that day, Israel will be a third
party with Egypt and Assyria." So watch
what he says about these three parties.
You got Israel. Listen,
>> whatever. You got Israel,
>> Egypt, and Assyria. Now watch what he
says. He says,
>> he says, uh, verse 24. So in that day,
Israel will be a third party with Egypt
and Assyria, a blessing in the midst of
the earth, whom Yahweh of Host has
blessed, saying, watch this, blessed is
Egypt, my people, and Assyria, the work
of my hands, and Israel, my inheritance.
So you have the you have the Egyptians,
not
>> Egyptians.
>> Yep. You got Egypt, who's called his
people. That's why you look at
Deuteronomy 28:68.
The southern tribes came and say, "And
the most high shall send you into Egypt,
which mean captivity, slavery, and
bondage again." Right.
>> Yeah. But are they with ships?
>> Yes. Are they Israelites or them as
Egypt? We always ran into
>> Where does the Bible call them Egypt?
>> We always call them Egypt. We always I
don't care about what you and the
Assyrian did with the northern tribes.
They would have kept Assyrian.
>> No. Where does the Bible have those that
inherit the righteous of the most high?
>> Where does the Bible call them that?
Where does the Bible call them to
Egyptians?
>> Where does the Bible call Israelites
This is the book of Isaiah.
>> We got we scattered among all nations.
Listen to it.
>> Isaiah 11:11. And it shall come to pass
in that day.
>> The Most High shall set his hand again
the second time to recover the remnant
of his people.
>> Remnant of his people. Read.
>> Which shall be left from Assyria.
>> Syria
>> and from Egypt.
>> And from Egypt. There go. As Syria and
Egypt there people that's there.
>> That's there. Israel
>> and from Pathro. You understand, man?
>> Are they Israel?
>> Our people are Egypt right now.
>> Our people are Egypt right now. Our
people are Syrian right now, aren't
they? Because you know why? Because we
went in a caption on Egyptians and we
always ran into Egypt. It's the mindset.
Show me the verse. Your mindset is just
like a gentile. You're a gentile. You're
not an Israelite. You're not a gentile.
>> You're right. Show me the verse.
>> Okay. Well, give me You're a stranger,
right? No. Show me.
>> Show me the verse that the Egyptian The
Israelite that's in Egypt or the
Israelite that's in Assyria is called an
Assyrian or an Egyptian. They call that
he reading about that's why God get them
from out of there.
>> Give me the verse.
>> He got to get them from out of there.
Where does he get?
>> Where does he call them Egyptians?
>> Huh?
>> He called them Egyptians all the time
because why? Where? Give me the verse.
>> Right here.
>> Right here. Our people programmed just
like you programmed. No. No. Hold up.
Get get this. Come on. No. Don't Don't
leave me hanging, man. It's good.
>> I You going to leave me hanging?
>> That's true.
>> You going to leave me hanging?
>> You leaving? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Before you leave, maybe one small
scripture. I'm hold hand to your name.
Hold this. Isaiah 14:1. Come on. Isaiah
14 and1. You ain't going nowhere. Yeah.
Hold on. Hold on. Isaiah 14 and1. Read
this. Isaiah 14:1.
>> Yo, strangers. Read.
>> For the Most High will have mercy on
Jacob.
>> Have mercy on Jacob. Read.
>> And will yet choose Israel.
>> Will yet choose Israel. Read.
>> And set them in their own land.
>> Set us in our own land. Read. And the
strangers,
>> the strangers you looking out for, read,
>> shall be joined with them,
>> join with us, read.
>> And they shall cleave to the house of
Jacob.
>> Cleave in the house of Jacob. Read.
>> And the people shall take them and bring
them to their place.
>> Take these strangers that learn the ways
of the Israelites. Going to take them
and bring us to their place. Read.
>> And the house of Israel shall possess
them.
>> Possess these strangers for what?
>> In the land of Yahawah.
>> In the land of the most high. For what?
for servants,
>> men slaves, re
>> and handmmaids
>> and handmmaids. Women slaves read.
>> And they shall take them captives.
>> Take them captives. Read
>> whose captives they were.
>> We going to take them captives whose
captives we were. And all throughout the
Bible, we in captivity. Read. Most of
the time, read.
>> And they shall rule over their
oppressors. Going to rule over our
oppressors, man. Straight up. I mean,
they going they have a chance to go
through the kingdom. That's their
position.
>> Glory be to God.
>> That's their position. Glory be to God.
that not every nation 14
>> not every nation was an oppressor of
Israel and on top of that 14 you got you
got Israel who is third hold on brother
you got Israel who is a third in a party
Israel and even you said Israel that's
the 12 tribes you said that earlier then
you got Egypt and then you got Assyria
>> so what about what about the other other
nations what about Edom what about Moab
what about what about Ham what about
doing one thing at a No, the focus that
you said is nations. According to
according to the scripture, it's not
just Israel that's his people. It's not
just Israel that's his people, but it's
also the Egyptians and it's also the
Assyrians. So, you got to deal with
that, brother.
>> Right. Isaiah,
>> I appreciate this though. This was a
good conversation, brother. Take care,
man. Come back next week.
>> Isaiah 13 to 14.
>> But I'll be back again.
>> And it shall be as the chase grow. They
going to be like a chase there, brother.
Yeah,
>> it is a sheep that no man taketh up.
>> Well, you looking out for it going to be
like a sheep with no man taketh up. It's
good.
>> They shall every man turn to his own
people.
>> Every man going to turn to his own
people. Re just do a quick wrap into his
own land.
>> They couldn't deal with a single verse.
>> Not one verse could deal with Israel
being a third party with Assyria and
Egypt. Egypt being called my people by
God. They couldn't deal with the verse.
They couldn't deal with the verse where
it says that the kingdom, the power, and
the authority is going to be made up of
a people from every tribe, nation, and
tongue. They ran from that. They ran
from every single verse talking about
the covenant. The stranger who was a
non-Israelite was sworn into the
covenant. Couldn't deal with that. You
guys got all these verses. Take note.
They have no answers for these verses.
That's a wrap. This is what we do, baby.
to them. You going to what?
>> Oh my god. Logic.
[Music]